weeks ago members of The White House
staff protested against their own
president uh we are Congressional
staffers on Capitol Hill also and we are
no longer comfortable staying silent
well you're staffers you're supposed to
stay silent what are you talking about
yeah you my boss is doing a job and I
thought I'd go public with it I mean
this is hundreds of people in Biden's
staff and on on uh Cong Democrat
Congressional Democrat staff who are
publicly going against them because
they're not supporting Hamas enough you
fire them period you fire all of them
that's it it's not it's not up for
debate if you had if you had five
staffers standing outside saying Bill
marah's the devil what are you going to
do you're going to fire them right of
course you're going to fire them it's as
simple as that you fire these people but
the inmates are running the Asylum if
the staffers don't like what they're
doing you fire them that's it but but we
are watching the collapse of all of our
systems